a peur 24' très chargé décidément
françois mitterrand la nuit dernière il
était à luxembourg ce matin une
rencontre est donc le numéro un polonais
et en tout début d'après-midi et bien
ils partent pas pour les antilles une
visite officielle de trois jours qui
commencera la martinique le chef de
l'état y est arrivé tout à l'heure à
bord d'un concorde de spécial d'air
france à la martinique il devrait
officiellement évoqué les problèmes
économiques
il se rendra ensuite en guadeloupe sera
d'ailleurs sa première visite officielle
dans ces deux îles en voie bus le chef
de l'état devrait aborder des problèmes
du politique
après les poussées de fièvre indépendant
il fera